in this video we're going to explore the
idea of an indifference curve
in difference
indifference curve
and what it is is it it describes all of
the points all the combinations of
things to which i am indifferent in the
past we've thought about maximizing
total utility now we're going to talk
about all the combinations that
essentially give us the same total
utility so let's draw
let's let's draw
a graph
that tells us all of the different
combinations of two goods to which we
are indifferent and like i've we've
mentioned before we're focusing on two
goods because we did three goods we
would have to do it in three dimensions
and four goods would get very abstract
so let's say in this axis the vertical
axis this is going to be the quantity
and we'll stay with the chocolate and
the fruit trade-off those are the only
two things that we consume so this is
going to be the quantity of chocolate in
bars
and in the horizontal axis is going to
be the quantity of fruit and this is
going to be in pounds of fruit and this
will go see this is 10
this is 20. this is 10
and this is 20 and this would be 15 5 5
and then 15. and let's say
let's say that right now
at some point i am consuming
5 pounds of fruit per month and 15 bars
of chocolate per month so that would put
me right there and if someone were to
ask sal
how would you feel how would you feel if
instead of that instead of that i were
to give you
let's say 10 pound 10 bars of chocolate
and seven pounds
and seven pounds of fruit and i would
say you know what i'm indifferent i
wouldn't care whether i have so this
right over here is
i don't i wouldn't care where there are
15 bars of chocolate and
five pounds of fruit or whether i have
ten bars of chocolate and seven pounds
of fruit i am indifferent between these
two
i've introspected on what i like and
what i derive benefit and satisfaction
out of and i get the same total utility
out of either of these out of either of
these points so both of these are on the
same indifference curve and in general i
could plot all of the different
combinations that give me the exact same
total utility
and it might look something like this it
let me try to dart as neatly as possible
i'll do it in magenta
it might look something
something like this and then keep going
all the way down like that so any point
any point on this curve right over here
i'm indifferent relative to my current
predicament of 15 bars and 5 pounds of
chocolate so that is my indifference
curve
and difference
indifference curve
now let's think about so obviously if i
go all over here 20 pounds of choc 20
pounds of fruit and i don't know that
looks like about two bars of chocolate
to me the same utility based on my
preferences as where i started off with
so if someone just swapped everything
out i would just kind of i would kind of
just you know shrug my shoulder and say
yeah no big deal i'm exact i wouldn't be
happy i wouldn't be sad i am indifferent
now what about points what about points
down here what about a point like this
well that is clearly not preferable
because for example that point i just i
just showed i can show a point on the
indifference curve where i am better off
for example that point that i just did
that's five pounds of fruit and about
five bars of chocolate but assuming that
the marginal benefit of more chocolate
is positive and the way i've drawn this
it or the assumption is that it is then
i'm obviously getting more benefit if i
get even more chocolate per month
and so anything down here below the
indifference curve is not preferred
not preferred
preferred and using the same exact logic
anything out here
anything out here well that would be
good because we we're neutral between
all of these points on the curve but
this green point right over here i have
the same number of bars as a point on
the curve but i have a lot more i have a
lot more pounds of fruit looks like i
have 11 or 12 pounds of fruit so
assuming that i'm getting marginal
benefit from those incremental pounds of
fruit and we will make that assumption
then this right over here anything out
here is going to be preferred so this
whole area this whole area is going to
be referred to everything on the curve
preferred
and the whole area down here is
obviously we've
not preferred to anything on the curve
let me just to show you this not those
points that so all of this and let me do
that in a different color actually
because our curve is purple everything
in blue everything in blue is not
preferred
now the last thing i want to think about
in this video is what the slope of this
indifference curve tells us when i talk
about the slope and this is really kind
of an idea out of calculus because we're
used to thinking about slopes of lines
so if you give me a line like that the
slope is how much how much does my
vertical axis change for every change in
my horizontal axis so the typical
algebra class that axis is your y-axis
that is your x-axis and when we think
about slope we say okay when
i have a i have a certain change in y
when i change an x by one so we have
something like this so when i change
i get a certain change in y
the triangle means change in delta
change in y when i get a certain change
in x when i get a certain change in x
and delta y the change in y over change
in x is equal to the slope
but this is when it's a line and the
slope isn't changing at any point on
this line if i do the same ratio between
a change in y to change in x i'm going
to get the same value on a curve like
this the slope is constantly changing so
what we really do to figure out the
slope exactly the point you can imagine
it's really the slope of the tangent
line at that point a line that would
just touch at that point so for example
so for example let's say that i draw a
tangent line i'll draw my best attempt
at drawing a tangent line i'll do it in
pink let's say i have a tangent line
right from our starting predicament just
like that and it looks something like
that
it looks something like that
and so right where we are right where we
are now
exactly at this point exactly you know
if we veer away it seems like our slope
is is changing where in fact it
definitely is changing it's becoming
less deep as we go forward to the right
it's becoming more steep as we go to the
left but right there
the slope of the tangent line looks
right like that or you could view that
as the instantaneous slope right there
and we can measure the slope of the
tangent line we could say look if we
want if we want an extra extra let's see
this looks like about if we want an
extra two
if we want an extra two pounds of fruit
how many bars are we going to have to
give up
give up well it looks like we're going
to have to give up based on the slope
right over there looks like we're going
to have to give up 5 5 bars so this is 5
and this is 2. so what is your change in
what is the slope here the slope
the slope here
is going to be that your change in bars
and i should actually say this this is a
negative right over there it's going to
be your change in bars
your change in chocolate bars over the
the your change in fruit over your
change in fruit and in this ca in this
situation we it is negative 5
negative 5 bars for every two fruit that
you get so bars
bars per fruit
or you can say this is equal to negative
2.5 bars per fruit
bars per fruit so it's essentially
saying exactly at that point
how are you willing to trade off bars
for fruit exactly that point is going to
change as things change along this curve
but it's saying exactly where you're
sitting right now you would be
indifferent and it's only as you just
slightly move or for an extra drop of
fruit an extra ounce of fruit not even a
whole pound you'd be willing to trade
off two and a half bars per fruit and
what this says so you're willing to give
up since it's negative you're giving up
two and a half bars of chocolate for
every pound of fruit now it's going to
be different once you have a lot more
fruit you're going to be much less
willing to give up bars of chocolate
over here you have a lot of bars and not
a lot of fruit so you're willing to give
up a lot of bars for fruit
over here
if we go over here the slope looks a
little bit different over here it is
much flatter
it is much flatter so let me draw it in
a color we haven't used yet so over here
the tangent line looks something like
this
it looks something like this and let's
say when you calculate it when you
calculate it in order to get in order to
get i don't know this looks like about
five pounds of fruit in order to get
five pounds of fruit you are going to
have to give up you are going to have to
give up two bars so once again the slope
is the change in the vertical axis over
the change in the horizontal axis so
over here at this point your change in
bars
over your change in fruit
is going to be
well you're going to give up 2 bars for
every 5 fruit for every 5 fruit bars
bars per fruit
bars per fruit so this right over here
is negative
this is negative 0.4 negative 0.4 i'll
say b for f so over here you're willing
to give up much fewer bars for every
incremental fruit up here you were
willing to give many bars away for every
fruit and that made sense over here you
had a lot of chocolate bars not a lot of
fruit so you're willing to give up more
bars for your fruit and over here
you have many fewer bars so you're much
you're much more resistant to giving up
bars for fruit but this
number this number how many bars you're
willing to give up for an incremental
fruit at any point
at any point here or you could view it
as a slope of the indifference curve
the slope or the slope of a tangent line
at that point of the indifference curve
this right over here is called our
marginal rate of substitution
marginal
rate
of substitution it's a very fancy word
but all it's really saying is how much
you're willing to give up of the
vertical axis for an increment of the
horizontal axis right at that point it
changes as soon as you move because this
is a curve it changes a little bit but
right at that point for a super super
small amount how many how many bars are
you willing to give up for fruit and
obviously it changes as we go along this
indifference curve